Humanity's reaction to covid I assume
that you get into that in the book
so is the is the reaction and how split
everybody is right now is that explained
by Evolution
well let's just say it's not in the book
because we actually finished the first
draft we uh finished it in the Amazon
Heather and I went to a very remote
Field Station called tipatini which is
in the most diverse habitat on Earth we
went there to finish up what we had been
doing and that was January 2020. it was
January 2020. as we emerged from the
Amazon literally as our phones woke up
for the first time in a couple of weeks
we heard of Novel coronavirus for the
first time and wondered whether this was
going to be you know yet another close
call like the original SARS and MERS or
whether it might be something more but
the book was finished before covid
happened that said the toolkit in the
book does allow one to work
independently and to analyze what one is
hearing about the regression of the
pandemic and our response to it and and
we have found ourselves uh very
uncomfortably
in some controversy as a result of the
fact that a proper grounding in
evolution does suggest that our response
to this pandemic is uh largely
incoherent
um so that's probably not where we
should spend our time today okay okay
and
going sorry Heather you go ahead no you
go ahead well one of the interesting
things about the timing was that as
Brett said we submitted the first draft
and of course we had some more drafts
and so we did add a few little things
here and there we do have an afterbird
that just very very briefly addresses
sort of what the what the global
response to covet has has looked like
um but are what we then did almost as
soon as we submitted the first draft of
the book was we started this podcast of
our star course that Brett already
mentioned and that was started in part
as a response to what we were seeing as
very confusing public messaging Public
Health messaging around covet and so you
know from the very beginning for
instance we were saying
um wow the the evidence suggests for
instance that this is not a virus that
transmits outside this is not a disease
that you end up getting if you're
outside and furthermore if you do get it
if you spend time outside you're
probably going to be better off and so
um really it's the the logic that we are
trying to introduce people to in the
book The evolutionary logic of how is it
you know what are humans at an
evolutionary level and how can we
understand understand ourselves from our
historical perspective and also from the
perspective of how we have to move
forward so as to best make decisions and
not just make decisions but interpret
the pronouncements that are handed down
from on high you know do those
pronouncements make sense or don't they
so rather than follow the scientists you
know follow a scientific interpretation
of the world and try to make sense of it
for yourself that said uh one of the
central themes of the book is something
we call hyper novelty which is a state
of change that is so rapid that it
outstrips our capacity to evolve in
response which is a remarkable thing
because human beings are by far the
fastest evolving creatures that exist
because so much of what we do is
actually in the software layer rather
than in the hardware layer it can change
extremely rapidly but the pace of change
is just simply too high and all through
the pandemic you can see
um that this is occurring I mean even
just the simple fact of the rate at
which this disease spread around the
globe is the result of new technologies
that epidemiology uh is um now taking
advantage of like air travel for example
okay so let's talk about this hyper
novelty thing for for a sec so one of
the experiences I think my family's had
and you guys have definitely had
um is that
I guess I've been put in a position my
dad's certainly been put in a position
where things are happening so quickly
that like you said you can't adapt and
so everything seems a bit fake and I
would say most of society at the moment
is probably in a similar situation with
the pandemic where it's like is this is
this real so do you guys have ways to
combat that because I assume things are
just going to get weirder and faster and
weirder and faster with technology so
are there things we can do to get out of
this to like calm I guess our nervous
systems down and adapt properly
yeah I mean it depends on the domain but
but yes it's a short answer and you know
one of the things to do is to recognize
that it is the rate of change itself
that is speeding up and to do what you
can
um you know first at the individual
level to to slow your own experiences
down and that and and to make them more
real more embodied and that of course is
more difficult in a pandemic era where
so many of us are connecting over zoom
over over social media but also to
recognize and you know this is this may
seem like it's unrelated but but I think
it's related and it's definitely a theme
throughout the book that
um
humans
as many of us as think we are innumerate
and you know many people are sort of
proudly describe themselves as I don't
do math I don't understand numbers it is
still a tendency to once they hear a
number once they hear that this thing is
better than that or that this gives you
a hundred percent chance of something
right that it's those numbers that you
stick with and there's a reductionism
that this obscures that is is really an
error and you know people imagine that
if it's if it's a number it's scientific
and so we go after this what you know
what we think of as a pseudo-scientific
approach to an understanding of the
world that you can use scientific tools
where you're trying to recognize
patterns and you know as much as you can
about what it is that you are as a human
being and you recognize patterns and you
move forward with with care and rigor
and compassion for other human beings
but you don't assume that just because
something has been measured that that's
the thing that should have been measured
or that it is being conveyed to you
properly so that's that's part of it
it's also I mean it's consistent with
not being overly focused on the
quantification but the fact is you're
looking at patterns and they function
especially in the realm of biology in a
logical way and so one could in the
early days of the pandemic for example
make a lot of Headway by simply
reviewing the evidence that was emerging
and so we looked at the evidence that
said that a huge number of cases in Asia
had been looked at and with one
exception none could be traced to an
outdoor environment and we thought well
that rather changes everything doesn't
it it makes it appear potentially like
although we are being told that
everything is dangerous that in fact
most of the world above 99 that's
Outdoors might well be safe
well what does that mean it could mean a
number of things it could mean that UV
light from the sun is killing the virus
in which case you need to be careful at
night and not during the day well it
turned out UV light does kill the virus
but the virus still didn't transmit
Outdoors at night and so the model
developed and what we said back then was
take advantage of this this is a great
loophole that the the pandemic has in it
that we can make use of that we can live
normally Outdoors but
we have to be very careful because
viruses that come from wild creatures
and one way or another this one
ultimately has to have come from bats
those viruses have to transmit outdoors
and so if this virus has forgotten how
to do that it will learn it again if we
give it that opportunity
so we we cautioned people make use of
the outdoors take advantage of it
restore your Psychology by behaving more
normally outside but be cautious don't
give it the chance to move or it will
learn this trick and we will lose that
advantage and all of that was just
simply a matter of looking at evidence
figuring out what the patterns were and
extrapolating carefully from them
okay well that makes sense to me that's
certainly not what we did but it makes
sense
[Music]